PROFESSOR: All right.
So I left you at the end of
last lecture with this
incredible cliffhanger I put
up on the slide, but...
So let me get a running start
and let you know where we
were, finish up that lecture,
and then move in to
the topics for today.
So as you recall, at the end of
last lecture I was talking
about a particular critique
which has been offered by
contemporary social
psychologists of Aristotle's
moral theory.
As you recall, Aristotle has a
moral theory whose fundamental
notion is that of the person
with good character--the one
who acts as the well-raised one,
the person with practical
wisdom would act.
Aristotle calls that person
the phronimos.
And John Doris, in the essay
we read, gave voice to a
concern which a number of
philosophers have expressed in
recent years, which is the
concern that Aristotle's moral
theory commits a mistake.
It commits what psychologists
call the fundamental
attribution error.
And that's the idea that it's
character rather than
circumstance that's the primary
determinant of action.
And Doris adduced a number of
psychological studies that
purport to show that the primary
determinant of action
is circumstance rather
than some standing
feature of the person.
So he told us the story of the
guys in the phone booth and
suggested that it's a local
feature of mood that
determines whether people are
likely to be helpful rather
than a standing feature
of character.
He told us the story of the Good
Samaritan study, again
suggesting that it was
circumstance or situation that
affected behavior, not
standing features of character.
We ourselves read and thought
about the Milgram experiments:
circumstances in which people
find themselves behaving in
ways that one might think
are out of character.
And we talked about previously,
and we'll talk
about it again, the idea of
moral luck: the idea that one
may find oneself in
circumstances
that lead to behavior.
So there is no doubt that there
is an element of truth
to the claim that circumstance
is a major
contributor to behavior.
It's undeniable that there are
circumstances that contribute
to how it is that people act.
But that strand of social
psychology that Doris is
stressing is, I think, only
part of the story.
So in addition to circumstance
contributing to character,
there's a large body of research
in psychology known
as personality psychology which
looks at a set of traits
that seem to be pretty well
established in people by their
first year of life.
These are traits that are quite
stable over time, and
that end up correlating with a
large range of other measures.
These are things like openness
to new experience,
conscientiousness in carrying
out responsibilities,
extroversion as opposed to
introversion, agreeableness,
and neuroticism: a certain
kind of anxiety.
So although it is the case
that circumstance plays a
major role in determining how
it is that people behave, it
is also the case that there
are contributions from
individual personality.
And one of the most dramatic
pieces of evidence in favor of
that are Walter Mischel's famous
deferred gratification
studies which I'll discuss
now and then again
later in the lecture.
It looks like, if Mischel's
studies which involve
thousands and thousands of
children are to be trusted,
that the early capacity for
self-regulation or delay of
gratification in the face
of temptation is highly
predictive of all sorts of
things ranging from SAT scores
to social relations in school.
Social and cognitive functions
seem to correlate with the
certain features about
early experience.
So although it is undoubtedly
the case that the situationist
critique gets something right
and it is undoubtedly a
mistake to think that the sole
contribution to behavior is
character, and that the features
of the environment
play no role, to say that only
contribution to behavior is
circumstance and that there's no
contribution on the part of
the individual is, I
think, a mistake.
And those of you who are
interested in looking at what
those individual differences
look like in children early on
may enjoy watching some of the
videos of the Mischel studies
where you get to see children
sitting in front of
marshmallows, looking
like this, or
this, or this, or this.
Or--poor thing--she's destined
for low SAT scores, but wow is
that marshmallow going
to taste good.
So any of you who wants to watch
some of these, here are
three very different
presentations of the
marshmallow case.
And again, these slides will be
up so you can go get them
off the Internet.
OK.
So that's the closing of last
lecture, and obviously a
straightforward segue way into
the topic of today's lecture
which is the question in some
ways with which we began this
section of the course: the
question of strategies for
regulating oneself in the face
of weakness of the will.
Now, what we emphasized in last
lecture was Aristotle's
picture of what it takes for
someone to be virtuous.
And Aristotle said that in order
to be virtuous, you need
to satisfy four conditions.
You need to know what's the
right thing to do, you need to
decide to do that thing because
it's the right thing,
you need to do so stably, and
you need to do so in a way
that doesn't cut against
your inclinations.
Those are the four features
that are required to be
virtuous on Aristotle's
picture.
And corresponding to virtue on
the other end of the spectrum,
is the Aristotelian notion of
vice which is basically its
exact opposite.
It's a harmonious, stable,
knowledgeable, decided
tendency to act in keeping with
exactly what's wrong.
So the vicious person has
knowledge of what's the wrong
thing to do, decides to do it
because it's the wrong thing,
stably does so, and doesn't feel
any inclination to do the
right thing.
So those are two ends of the
Aristotelian spectrum.
In fact, there are two things
which lie a bit beyond the end
of the Aristotelian spectrum.
As you know from you reading
guide, Aristotle also
identifies the notion somewhat
akin to the state that
Jonathan Shay calls
the berserk state.
This is the state that Aristotle
calls bestiality, a
state below virtue and vice.
And he gives examples from some
of the Greek tragedies of
tearing a body apart
limb from limb.
So Aristotle thinks it's
possible to move out of the
moral realm altogether.
Vice, on the Aristotelian
picture, is still a kind of
stable and predictable way
to act in the world.
Bestiality lies below that.
And above virtue lies this
idea of divinity: a state
whereby regulating
with respect to
virtue isn't even required.
But the heart of the discussion
that we read in
chapter seven of Aristotle's
Ethics for today concerns
itself with this
range of states
between virtue and vice.
And Aristotle gives a really
nice taxonomy of those which I
think is helpful for
understanding what it is to
engage in self-regulation.
I should stress that I am no
Aristotle scholar, and that
what I'm providing is
a somewhat contrived
reconstruction.
But I think it's helpful for
getting a handle on what these
distinctions amount to.
So we might ask first, what
would a state look like that
shares with virtue that one
has knowledge of the right
thing to do, that one decides to
do it for that reason, and
that one has the inclination,
but that lacks a kind of
character, or logical stability,
that Aristotle
takes to be a hallmark
of true virtue?
That, I think, is the state
that Aristotle calls
temperance.
One's inclined to do the
right thing because
it's the right thing.
And one knows what the
right thing is.
But there isn't the sort of
predictable, law-like,
stability of character
that virtue requires.
Corresponding to temperance,
on the other side of the
scale, is what Aristotle calls
intemperance which is, in some
sense, the mirror image
of temperance.
Here one is simply inclined to
do the wrong thing because
it's the wrong thing.
But not as a hard feature of
character in the way that he
gives in the case of vice,
but just as a matter of
temperament.
So the temperate person,
with inclination,
does the right thing.
They're inclined to do
the right thing and
they act in that way.
The intemperate person, with
inclination, does the wrong
thing and feels no conflict
in the face of it.
What happens if we remove
another one of the
Aristotelian features?
What happens if we have
knowledge of what's the right
thing to do and the decision to
do the right thing, but our
inclination pulls us in
the other direction?
So we have made a decision to
act in keeping with what's
right, at least at an abstract
level if not a concrete one,
we have a sense of
what's right.
Aristotle says, and I put this
approximation in front of the
knowledge that "what the
continent and incontinent
person have is the recognition
of the general rule, but some
difficulty recognizing whether
the general rule applies in
this particular case." So the
continent person has a sense
of what the right thing to do
is, has made a decision to act
in keeping with that, but her
inclination pulls her in
another direction.
She finds it difficult to avoid
the chocolate cake.
She finds it difficult to get
up when her alarm rings.
She finds it difficult to resist
the marshmallow in
order to get the second.
But somehow she contains herself
and acts against her
inclination.
The mirror image of the
continent person is
Aristotle's incontinent
person.
In terms of their decision,
they are like
the continent one.
They want to do the thing that
corresponds with morality.
Like the continent person,
they have a sense of the
general rule, a little
difficulty seeing how it
applies in this particular
case.
And like the continent person,
they have an inclination to go
towards a pleasure which
attracts them.
But unlike the continent person,
the incontinent person
finds herself unable to overcome
the inclination.
And so, below the line,
she acts in
keeping with what's wrong.
Finally, Aristotle considers
a pair of cases where the
attraction to doing the wrong
thing is not a desire for a
pleasure, but a desire
to avoid pain.
So in some cases, one doesn't
get full credit for being
continent, one doesn't resist a
pleasure, but one is willing
to put up with a certain amount
of discomfort in the
face of doing the right thing.
Aristotle calls that resistance:
continence in the
face of pain.
And corresponding to that, below
the line, is softness:
incontinence in the
face of pain.
Doing the wrong thing because
one has given in to a certain
kind of discomfort.
So I put this list before you
because I think it's not
completely clear on a first
read, or a second, or a third,
or a fourth through Book Seven
of Aristotle's Ethics, how
carefully structured Aristotle's
picture of the
human soul and its strengths
and weaknesses is.
But I think that if we see
it as a set of paired
characteristics, each of which
lacks or has certain of the
features of paradigmatic
Aristotelian virtue, then we
can get a pretty clear sense
of what the Aristotelian
picture looks like.
And I encourage you, armed with
this framework, to go
back to the text which we've
been reading over and over in
this class: the text at the end
of Book One and beginning
of Book Two of Aristotle's
Ethics.
And try, yet again, to see what
the picture of virtue is
that Aristotle is
concerned with.
So what I want to do in the
remainder of the lecture today
-- and we're going to need our
clickers pretty soon --
is to talk about Aristotle's
idea of incontinence.
What it is to be in a situation
where one knows what
the right thing to do
is, in the abstract.
One's committed to doing
the right thing.
But one has an inclination
that pulls in the other
direction, and one gives
in to that inclination.
So we're to ask, by starting
to give you a choice.
And let me say, this
is a real poll.
I have here the money, right
here in this envelope.
And I have here --
I'm not kidding --
I have here a class list. And
during the ten seconds that
you're answering this poll, I
will close my eyes and select
a name from the class list. So
I'm asking you right now.
You'll have 10 seconds once
I start the timer to
choose what you want.
One of you is really going to
get either $5 right now, or $6
on Thursday.
And It could be you.
OK.
So clickers out.
We have 10 seconds left.
OK.
So let's see what the responses
are on this.
OK.
22% of you want $5 now.
78% of you want $6
in two days.
Sarah Cox?
Sarah Cox, are you here?
Sarah Cox, which
did you choose?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, I'll keep this right with
me, and I'll put it in my
copy of Aristotle's Ethics.
So I'm good for my word.
OK.
22% of you, however, would
be just getting the
envelope right now.
OK, second poll.
Which do you choose?
And again, I have money.
I have a second envelope.
It's in my bag.
And you can choose $5 in 35
days, or $6 in 37 days.
OK?
$5 in 35 days, or
$6 in 37 days.
Polling open.
Ten seconds.
Ten, nine, eight --
$5, 35 days. $6 in 37 days.
And let's see how the
numbers came out.
OK.
All right.
You experimental error folks are
very good at showing the
experimental error aspect of
pushing buttons on these.
Or maybe, maybe there are
some of you who see
this as being different.
OK, 20% of you were preferring
to take $5 today over 6$ on
Thursday, even though almost
none of you wanted to take the
same decision in a month.
Now, let me point something out
to you which, of course,
to the rational part of your
soul is completely obvious.
These bets are identical.
I offered you $5 on the 15th
versus $6 on the 17th.
Or I offered you $5 on the 22nd
versus $6 on the 24th.
When it comes to the 22nd of
March, oh 22% of you, who gave
different answers in these two
cases, you will be in exactly
the same situation with respect
to the $5 and $6 that
you are with respect to the
$5 and $6 right now.
There's no difference between
this choice and this choice.
Nonetheless, it turns out to be
consistently the case that
human beings and non-human
animals have a tendency to
start acting differently towards
delayed rewards when
they are happening in the far
future and when they are
happening in the near future.
So for many decades the
psychologist, George Ainslie,
has studied decisions that have
the following structure.
One has a choice between a
smaller reward that one can
get sooner, like the $5 as
opposed to the $6, or a larger
reward that one can get later.
And Ainslie has studied this
phenomenon in the context of
human and non-human animals.
And I'm going to read aloud a
quote to you, which will be up
on the slides on the web site,
that gives you a sense of what
this phenomenon amounts to.
Ainslie calls it hyperbolic
discounting.
And he says "people often, and
lower animals always, discount
the prospect of future rewards
in a curve that's more deeply
bowed than a rational,
exponential curve."
So it's perfectly rational to
discount future rewards if
there's uncertainty
involved, right?
If I offered you $5 now or $6
in 20 years, it would make
perfect sense to take the $5
now because your degree of
uncertainty about whether
you would get the $6 is
sufficiently great with respect
to your degree of
certainty that you
would get the $5.
But the difference, I hope,
between thinking whether you
and I and this classroom are
going to be around this
Thursday, as opposed to three
weeks from now on a Thursday,
is trivial.
"Over a range of delays,"
continues Ainslie, "from
seconds to decades, there are
pairs of alternative rewards
such that subjects prefer the
smaller, earlier reward over
the larger later alternative
when the delay to the smaller
reward will be short." Right?
Those of you who preferred
$5 today as
opposed to $6 on Thursday.
"But prefer the larger, later
reward when the smaller
alternative will be more
delayed." $5 in 35 days versus
$6 in 37 days.
"Even though the time from the
earlier to the later reward
stays the same.
The curves that fit the
observed data best are
hyperbolic.
That is, they show value as
inversely proportional to
delay."
So again, what happens is, that
for a period of time, A,
the larger reward is preferred
to the smaller one, right?
That's you.
It's in 37 days.
It's in 36 days.
It's in 35 days.
It's in 34 days.
All that time, you prefer the
$6 two days later to the $5
now, or to the $5 two
days earlier.
And then all of a sudden as
the event draws near, the
value of the smaller reward
looms larger in your mind.
Decision after decision
has this structure.
Suppose you want to train to be
a competitive cyclist, or
some sort of athletic endeavor,
that's your larger,
later reward.
Suppose that one of the things
that's incompatible with your
becoming a competitive cyclist
is the eating of Crisco
covered cupcakes.
You're walking along, and at the
beginning it's completely
clear to you that what you
prefer is to be a cyclist. You
wake up in the morning, you say:
"what I'm going to do is
plan for my bicycling.
I'm not going to be distracted
by stupid things like Crisco
covered cupcakes." And you walk
along and still to you
now, there's your eyes, you
see ahh, the reward of the
bicycle is greater than the
reward of the cupcake.
And all of a sudden as the
cupcake grows nearer, you take
the smaller, sooner reward and
the larger, later falls out
from possibility.
Suppose you resolve that
tomorrow morning you're going
to get up super early to write
your paper for Philosophy 181,
COGSCI 281.
And so you set your alarm,
and you have the
ringing of the alarm.
And when you go to bed
you set it for 5:30.
You can see that larger later
reward is a bigger one.
And it comes to be 5:30 in the
morning and the alarm is
ringing, and you turn it off.
And oops, away goes the
possibility of the larger,
later reward.
Or suppose you're one of
Mischel's subjects in the
marshmallow study.
Here's your larger, later
reward: two marshmallows.
Here's your smaller, sooner
reward: one marshmallow.
Ask in the abstract, it's
pretty clear to you two
marshmallows is definitely
better than one
marshmallow until --
until what?
Until you're sitting in the room
with the one marshmallow
and oops, you lost
your chance.
So what I want to do in the
remainder of the lecture
today, is talk a little bit
about the psychological state
of the children involved in
Mischel's studies, and then
connect that for you to some
more general research on
self-regulation.
And finally connect that to the
discussion of principles
that we had in our reading
from Nozick today.
So when Walter Mischel began
doing these marshmallow
studies roughly 40 years ago,
there was a theory in place
that the best way to engage in
self-regulation was to think
about the reward that you were
going to get if you did the
right thing.
So on that theory, the best
way for kids to be able to
resist the one marshmallow
in order to get the two
marshmallows would be for the
experimenter to make it
incredibly vivid to them that
if they waited, they could
have two marshmallows.
So kids were brought into the
room in one of two conditions.
In one of the conditions, there
was one marshmallow over
here and two marshmallows
over there.
The rewards were visible.
The kids came in.
And they lasted, on average,
about four minutes before they
reached over and grabbed the
single marshmallow, thereby
losing the second.
When the rewards were hidden,
however, when the kids
couldn't see the marshmallows
and were brought into the room
and told you can either have one
marshmallow now, or if you
can wait long enough, you can
have two marshmallows.
Kids waited, on average,
12 minutes.
Then Mischel wondered what was
driving the capacity of the
children with hidden rewards to
sustain their self-control
long enough.
So the second condition he tried
was to take the kids who
were in the circumstance where
the rewards were hidden, and
tell them to think really hard
about the reward, think really
hard about those marshmallows.
The effect of thinking hard
about the marshmallows was
that the performance dropped to
exactly the level that it
had been in the case of
the kids for whom
the reward was visible.
And in fact, thinking about the
reward in the visible case
made it no worse.
So the problem was that when you
thought about the reward,
it became salient and resistance
became difficult.
So, thought Mischel, what if
we try it the other way?
What if we take the kids for
whom the reward is visible and
ask them to think happy
thoughts about
something else, right?
Look around the room, recite
the alphabet, tell yourself
the story about the three little
pigs, do something to
keep yourself distracted.
And the result was that if the
kids thought distracting
thoughts, they acted exactly
as the kids in the hidden
rewards situation.
And it made no difference in the
hidden situation to think
distracting thoughts.
So the presence of the
temptation before your mind is
part of what makes the
temptation difficult to
resist. And indeed,
Mischel thought
about this more generally.
He presented kids with either
a photograph or a real
marshmallow, it didn't matter
which, and asked them either
to pretend that it was real or
to think about tasting this,
think about how excellent that
marshmallow is going to taste.
And the delay which kids were
able to impose upon themselves
averaged about six minutes.
Whereas when he had even a real
marshmallow before them,
and asked the kids to pretend
that it's imaginary or to
think about it abstractly,
think about the number of
marshmallows there are, think
about the letter that the word
marshmallow starts with, think
about the nature of a candy
store and how --
I mean, these are four-year-olds
--
think about the nature of a
candy store and how candy
stores work in an
abstract sense.
Kids were able to regulate
themselves for 18 minutes.
So what was going on here?
What ties together the cases
where we get very short
numbers: kids are only able to
last four minutes, then give
in to the temptation.
And what ties together
the cases where
we get large numbers?
Mischel's hypothesis, and this
fits with the material that we
discussed on January 20th, is
that there are two systems of
processing rewards.
There's a hot system which
acts on what Plato or
Aristotle would call appetite,
or perhaps spirit.
It acts on the basis
of passion.
And when we think about things
with a vivid, emotional
attraction to them, that system
gets activated and
Plato's horses, Aristotle's
non-rational parts, system
one, aliefs and all the
rest get going.
That's the system that's active
when the rewards are
visible and there's
no instruction.
When you're thinking vividly
about the rewards, the
appetitive parts of soul are
brought on line, and
resistance to temptation
becomes difficult.
By contrast, when kids are asked
to think abstractly or
to pretend that the marshmallow
is imaginary, a
cool, rational system--a
system that is the one
involved in belief that is
Plato's charioteer, that is
the System Two of the dual
processing tradition--that is
the belief in the alief-belief
tradition--comes on line.
And in the face of this cool
processing system, which gives
us a sort of rational distance
from what we confront, all of
a sudden self-regulation
becomes possible.
So Mischel's studies fit in
to a larger framework for
thinking about how to
overcome temptation.
One which you'll not be
surprised to hear is
articulated, as is almost
everything that we're thinking
about in this course, in one
of the two great founding
narratives of the Western
literary tradition--in this
case, Homer's Odyssey.
Odysseus, pictured here in
elegant, white tunic, is
trying to get home from
the Trojan War.
He's trying to get back to his
wife who is waiting faithfully
for him at home, and it's
taking him about
20 years to do so.
And along the way as he tries to
go home, he faces all sorts
of temptations which threaten
to divert him from his path.
And the temptation that he
faces in this picture,
illustrated here in the form
of these beautiful flying
women who look, to me, a little
bit like dementors from
Harry Potter.
He, however, finds them
enormously tempting.
And he's trying to figure out
how to get the ship past the
sirens, whose songs threaten to
cause the ship to founder
upon the shoal, so that he
can get home to Penelope.
And what he comes up with are
two different strategies.
The first strategy he applies
to his sailors.
You will see that around
the ears of each of
them is cotton batting.
He blocks their ears so that
the apparent utility of the
sirens is reduced for them.
Unable to hear their song, the
sailors are able to continue
rowing the boat past their
source of temptation.
What he does to himself, as
you can see, is he has
himself, at point A on the
Ainslie curve, lashed to the
mast. Because, like Mischel's
children and like Ainslie, he
recognizes that when the siren's
song is available to
him directly, he will be in
that B state where the
smaller, sooner reward--like
turning off your alarm clock
or eating that cupcake--looms
larger to him.
So what Odysseus does is, he
ties himself to the mast. Even
though the temptation of the
reward is evident to him, he
has rendered himself unable
to act on that temptation.
And there is a tradition, in
the contemporary decision
theory literature, to use this
metaphor of Ulysses and the
sirens, Odysseus and the
sirens depending which
translation you use of the
name, to think about
strategies for self-regulation.
And it turns out that it's
helpful, I think, to think
about these strategies as
falling into three categories.
If you're trying to get past
a temptation that has the
structure that we've been
looking at in this class, of
smaller, sooner reward that,
because of temporal
discounting, looms
disproportionately large in
your decision structure.
One way to get around it is by
means of external constraints.
You can separate yourself from
the ability to act on the
temptation.
You can turn off the Internet on
your computer, you can use
one of those cell phone condoms,
you can render
yourself unable to act on the
basis of that which is going
to distract you from
your path.
You can put your alarm clock
all the way across the room
you can take the cupcakes out
of your house, you can put
your credit card in a glass
of water in the freezer.
All of these are ways of
separating yourself from the
ability to act on
the temptation.
Or you can separate yourself
from the appeal of the
temptation in some way.
You can reduce its subjective
utility to you by, for
example, blocking your ears so
you won't even notice that the
temptation is there.
So that's a way of externalizing
responsibility
for decision making
in this case.
And it's an extraordinarily
effective way of
self-regulating.
You are an agent in the world.
The actions which you're
going to perform are
actions on the world.
And separating yourself from the
ability to perform those
actions is one way to get
around temptation.
A second way to get around
temptation, which we've
discussed a lot in the last
two classes, is by direct
appeal to the spirited or
appetitive parts of your soul.
So you can manipulate incentive
structures for yourself.
You can change the relative
utilities
of the various rewards.
You can subject yourself to
interpersonal pressures.
Remember we put the smiley faces
on your computers so
that the gaze of the eyes of
others would help you stick to
your tasks.
Or you can cultivate
habits, right?
You can get spirit and appetite
into line with reason
by cultivating natural ways
of responding to things.
But the third way that you can
get around temptations, is the
one which we haven't discussed
yet, and that
is by means of reason.
And it is in this light that
Nozick discusses the roles
that principles can play in
allowing us not to be
incontinent.
So Nozick points out, quite
generally, that what
principles do is they group
actions by putting them under
a general rubric so that linked
actions are viewed or
treated in the same way.
If one takes on as a principle
to be a vegetarian, then any
act of eating meat is seen as a
violation of that principle.
Even if one thinks there are
circumstances where eating
meat might be the right thing to
do, all things considered.
What the principle does is to
classify that act with other
acts of eating meat so that the
actions become symbolic of
one another.
Smoking a single cigarette isn't
so bad, but smoking lots
of cigarettes is.
And one thing that a principle
can do is to let you have any
one instance stand as
an example of all.
Principles, says Nozick,
constitute a way of binding
ourselves to the mast, not
through external constraints
like ropes, but through internal
commitments to
following their mandates.
And he points out that
principles are affected in a
wide range of cases.
Intellectually, if you have
the idea that there's a
principle that connects one set
of facts to another, then
the principle can transmit
probability or support.
The old cases came out
a particular way.
Every time you observed a
certain kind of causation, it
had a particular structure.
You identified a principle, and
you're now in a position
to make predictions
about new cases.
Interpersonally, they
let you appear to
be a reliable person.
Your past actions were of
a certain kind, right?
Every time I said I would give
you money, I gave you money.
So you can conclude on that
basis I have a principle:
repay my debts.
And on that basis, you predict
my future actions.
It's in fact, exactly because
of that, that I switched all
the written exercises to
Thursdays rather than having
extensions on some of them.
My thought was this: suppose I
had given extensions on two of
the essays from Tuesday
to Thursday?
I'd look unprincipled about the
regulations for this course.
How will I be in a position
to enforce the course's
requirements if I appear
unprincipled?
Ah, suppose I adopt a new
principle, the Thursday due
date, with respect to which
I am unwavering?
Introspect a minute.
Strangely, that seems more
authoritative than having most
of them due on Tuesdays
and some on Thursdays.
Intrapersonally, conceptualizing
oneself in
terms of principles gives a kind
of narrative continuity
to one's life.
My past self was the kind of
person who would never do X.
My past self is the kind of
person who always does Y.
Articulating it in terms of a
principle lets me connect my
future self to my past self.
It gives me a sense of
continuity over time.
And finally, intrapersonally,
principles provide ways of
overcoming temptation.
Ooh, every time I see a cupcake
I want to eat it, but
if I have a principle that I
don't eat dessert after 4:00
pm, then it's easy.
I don't have to make
a decision on a
case-by-case basis.
The single act of eating
that cupcake once.
Why that once?
Why wouldn't I then do it all
the time becomes a way of
committing myself to
future actions.
Those of you who practice an
instrument know that the
easiest practice schedule is
to practice every day.
Because if you practice every
day, there's no question of
whether this is one
of the days that
you're going to practice.
If you are committed to a
certain kind of religious
behavior, or a certain kind of
dietary restriction, or a
certain kind of exercise
regimen, the easiest way to
implement it is to say always,
with respect to this domain,
will I behave in those ways.
And, in fact, Nozick suggests
that this is exactly the way
to use principles to get
past the Ainslie curve.
The mark of a principle, he
says, is that it ties the
decision whether to do an
immediate particular act to a
whole class of actions
of which the
principle makes it part.
The act now stands for
the whole class.
I discovered that I'm overusing
a particular kind of
relaxational substance
on weekends.
And the most straightforward
way for me deal with that
situation is to put
a categorical
restriction on my behavior.
Moreover, points out Nozick,
I can make use of a really
interesting irrationality
about myself to fight
irrationality with
irrationality.
Remember, I pointed out to you
a few lectures ago, that
people who lose a $10 bill on
the way to the theater are
happy to buy a new ticket
when they get there.
But people who lost a $10
ticket on the way to the
theatre are unhappy to do so.
That's an instance of a general
phenomenon known as
sunk costs, that when we've
invested a lot of effort in
something, we're reluctant to
stop acting on its basis, even
if right then we don't prefer
to do it anymore.
And so Nozick suggests that if
during A, that period leading
up to the Ainslie curve, we
invest many resources in the
future in pursuit of the larger
reward, the fact that
we tend not to ignore sunk costs
provides us with a way
to get past the temptation
during the period, B, to
choose the smaller, sooner.
If I decide I want to go to six
plays a year and I buy six
tickets, then even if it's
raining on one of the nights
that I was supposed to go, my
tendency towards sunk costs
will help me act on my action.
All right, last two minutes.
Let me connect this
to what we've done
and where we're going.
This, as you know, is the last
lecture in the first unit of
the course.
We began this unit by reading
Dan Ariely's Predictably
Irrational popular chapter--and
we ended this
unit by reading Ariely's
Predictably Irrational popular
chapter on procrastination.
But, unlike your experience on
January 11th, you now have a
philosophical framework in which
to place his discussion.
Unlike on January 11th, you
now have a psychological
framework in which to place
his discussion.
You've read Haidt, you've read
Batson, you've read the dual
processing work, you've read
Milgram, and Shay, and
Stockdale and Kazdin.
And you've read his own
scientific presentation of the
case, and you've thought about
the connections between them.
What comes next?
What comes next is a chance, in
your 5th and 6th directed
exercises, to address three
psychology articles which you,
yourself, are going to choose
and summarize, and then come
up with an experiment
on the basis of.
What comes next is a chance to
think about the philosophical
framework by writing your
first and second essays.
And what comes at the end of the
course, and I'll preview
it now, is a chance to think
about the connections between
them in the context of your
final directed exercise.
Which is going to be to design
a week of the course yourself
in which you choose texts
that you think multiply
illuminate the topic.
So next lecture we'll move on to
our discussion of morality.
And I'll connect it back to some
of the issues we've been
talking about so far.
And I look forward to seeing
you on Thursday, and
especially to giving away the
$6 to the very rational
student who was lucky
enough to earn it.